hey guys my name is Jess it is Wednesday
you're watching games but you can hear
something going on this enthrall you
MOBA fans the heroes of the storm 2.0
update has been detailed after the
coming update heroes of the storm will
no longer have level-cap currently
player progression is capped at level 40
and individual heroes at 20 the system's
will be unified and your player level
will now be the sum of all your hero
levels gained and good news if you've
been playing since hitting the level cap
all XP earned will be brought over to
the new system so your characters will
be leveled accordingly the XP gaps
between levels have also been reduced to
make leveling faster so you can take
advantage of another major addition a
loot boxes the newly implemented loot
chest system similar to what you'd find
in overwatch will reward you with four
new items per chest there are common
chests as well as rare and epic chests
that are awarded for reaching specific
milestones so just may include playable
heroes portraits voice lines and
announcer packs there's also a bunch
more cosmetic items like sprays and
banners on top of all that heroes of the
storm will be adding a new assassin hero
Kassia the open beta for heroes of the
storm 2.0 starts today
additional 2.0 content and details will
be revealed in the coming weeks so be
sure to subscribe and head to game smart
for all the info you may notice your
Xbox one home screen looking a little
different after you've installed the
latest system update the home screen now
has a much smaller icon for the game
you're playing and provides options to
jump to related areas such as the game's
hub art from the game will also be used
as the background providers you don't
have a custom background already set the
guide screen is now accessible by one
click of the Xbox button rather than to
in the refined guide you'll find tabs
that allow you to move between the home
screen my games and apps the Xbox store
recently launched apps pins and a whole
bunch of other things for those of you
who like to share your gameplay it's now
easier for you to access the games
easier menu on top of that integration
with the beam live streaming service has
been rolled out for Xbox one and
in those ten will be receiving the
service through an update on April 11
for the full details on the update along
with the video of the new features ahead
to our story on games but if you're a
PlayStation fan feeling a little left
out and not to worry as your free
PlayStation Plus games for April I have
been announced on ps4 you'll be able to
pick up the previously announced two
brand new drawn to death as well as
lovers in a dangerous space-time coming
to Vita and subsequently ps4 through
cross site is ten seconds ninja and
curses and chaos and those of you who
are still clinging on to your ps3 will
be treated with Invisibles The Lost
Kingdom and the extended edition of
alien rage all those freebies will
arrive on April 4 so make sure you take
up much as games which include tearaway
unfolded and disc gem before they
disappear that's everything we've got
for you today do let me know what you
cared about down in that comment section
and I will see you again with a bunch
more new smart